Walter is with us in Yuma Arizona hey
Walter welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
captain sir thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so my wife and I are
doing very well we're on baby step two
we've cleared out all of our credit card
debt and we're about to turn the corner
this next year and clear out all the
student loans and the car payments so
we're on we're on track to do what we
want to do but I like to think two and
three years down the line the situation
that we're in right now is that we we're
renting an apartment and I we have both
in firm agreement agreeance that we do
not want to buy a home out when we are
in a position of debt rather than be in
a position of power it's a question that
I have is that it's a two-part question
one is being the military the the
concept that you guys have in your book
that we've read is that the income is
your best building tool the allowance
for housing that we would get if we were
to live off-base would actually allow us
the affords the opportunity to be able
to get a home but we don't know how to
do that if it's either through the VA
loan or through the FHA loan
underwriting all this out right here's
the thing neither both of those are the
most expensive loans the VA is the most
expensive conforming loan unless you're
disabled veteran the fees and the gotcha
things that they built into it make it
an unattractive loan which is sad
because it's supposed to be a benefit
for you guys that have served and thank
you for your service
number two FHA is more expensive the
most inexpensive is a Fannie Mae an FN
ma loan a conventional mortgage and
that's what you'd be looking for at the
time you're ready to do this and of
course you've heard me it sounds like
say to have a 15-year fixed-rate where
the payment is no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay the other thing I would
warn you about being in the military is
this as you are already aware they move
you a lot and if you're not gonna bill
it in an area long enough for the house
to go up in value you could get stuck
with a high
there's kind of two types of areas that
military bases and installations are
around okay there's the small town that
is a military town and so constantly
there's a stream of houses that are
being put on the market and sold because
they're constantly moving military
people in and out of there that usually
hurts the market when you get ready to
sell because there's a huge supply of
other people trying to sell and
consequently the prices don't go up
quite as much so the other type of base
or installation they put you in is in a
metro area or an area that for whatever
reason has a very hot economy and so you
know you're in the Navy and you're in
San Diego well that economy that markets
booming independent of the military and
so if you get ready to sell there you
can sell that house and it will have
gone up in value so what you want to do
when you get ready to make the decision
whether to purchase in a given area is
you ask the real estate agent in the
area and go to one of our LPS and you're
looking for two statistics from the
Multiple Listing Service and they can
pull it straight out of their computer
statistic number one is what's the
average appreciation rate in your area
okay how much the houses go up in
percentage average in the area that
you'd be looking in the neighborhood the
general area and the town okay the
second thing you're looking for is dma
days on the market deal in days on the
market and how'd you know what that
means is how long does it take a house
to sell so if you're in an area that
goes up 8% a year and the average days
on the market is 27 days and you're
gonna live there three years well the
things going to go up 25% in that three
years and you're gonna be able to sell
it quickly when you leave you'll make
money on that you see what I'm saying
yeah but if those two statistics sound
like this sound like
percent appreciation and average days on
the market is 270 which is nine months
you're gonna lose your butt when you
leave after three years you're gonna
have by the time you pay expenses and
they can't get the thing sold that's not
a market that's a market that's slower
it's not as a dynamic it's not doing
well and you just don't buy there you
rent if you're stationed there okay so
if we're able to satisfy those two
statistics then you can make an argument
for yes living off base and no law and
just making that investment yes I'm the
government too much our selves
absolutely absolutely
now the off-base housing allowance is a
part of the equation but more than
anything else you'll make money even if
they didn't give you that by owning the
real estate and you know the quality of
life and so forth off base and
everything for your family it's
different and so you know but you do not
want to go into and I'm not gonna
mention names because then people get
mad at me but you know the types of
areas I'm talking about that the
military serve in I serve you guys in
the military we come to your areas all
the time and do stuff and so our people
do and so I go into the area where
there's really the entire economy in the
particular or of the virtual virtually
the entire economy in the particular
little town is military and you're not
getting out of there alive with a house
you're gonna get yourself skinned don't
buy in that market you know what I'm
saying okay so okay well this is a very
informative I think three times and
thank you for your service we're here to
help you guys man we appreciate you